well let's let's talk about your article
alan we have the story from breitbart
legion of doom 26 leftist ngos team up
to stop elon musk from changing twitter
alan what's this all about
so the left as you all know been
freaking out non-stop for the past uh
two or three weeks because of elon musk
who calls himself a free speech
absolutist and his plans to bring free
speech absolutism
back to twitter which is the correct way
of explaining it free speech was
originally an ideal of twitter uh they
changed that elon musk wants to take
them back to their roots what is this
and they can't let that happen because
who's this old guy uh i've never seen
that guy before who is he that's a good
question
yeah that's uh jack dorsey
jack dorsey that's the old ceo of
twitter he's not a jack dorsey that's uh
that's just getting that's dude
that is jorge
this is uh soros
george soros
wait are we allowed to say that i
thought that was like an anti-semitic
thing to even say his name isn't george
soros as i remember he said yeah
remember when um newt gingrich i think
it was who was it they mentioned george
soros on fox and fox was like no yeah
and he was like what he said george
soros was funding da's like no no we
don't talk about that and he was like
but he is like
i don't understand like it's not a
secret
yeah so so he's funding a lot of these
organizations that's going on he is uh
so are some foreign governments
so uh some foreign governments are
funding these organizations uh the
government of sweden the government of
canada denmark
uh the netherlands
foreign interference in our elections
yep indeed heavens foreign manipulation
of science i can't believe this there's
no way the left would be that
hypocritical next your talent you're
going to tell me that the left is
advocating for using horse medicine to
induce abortions
oh wait they are
this is part of what make it up when i
think people is upset maybe not
obsession with nationalism but like
adherence to nationalism worries me
because it's like
let's be realistic we're on a global
stage now everything is global there is
no more i mean there is still united
states constitution but the united
states is permeable everything is here
we're all interacting with each other at
this point this is this is literally
what jack dorsey was saying on on rogan
he was like well we're making rules for
i think it was actually vagina we're
making rules for our global community
and i'm like this is america
this is america we got american law here
you don't
silence someone for some some other
country what are you talking about yeah
and that's that's all musk has said he
said he uh wants free speech on twitter
to go as far as the law and no further
that's a very reasonable position and he
said people can change the law he's like
if they don't like it they gotta change
they can change the law you can well you
remember when uh when there was a debate
as to whether this acquisition would
take place uh saudi prince came out and
said you know they had a huge stake in
twitter and they were like absolutely
not the reason is because they need to
be able to censor their own citizens and
their own citizens are using twitter i
love this take a look at this the full
list includes free press
ah yes the free press
you may remember them from such
campaigns like stop people from having
free press yeah
what
is this freepress.net classic is that
who that is i think it's the same one
yeah because i want to give a shout out
to freepress.net because i know some of
the people who used to work there and i
remember you know back during occupy
when they were very much like free press
free speech
until
donald trump got elected and then they
were like we should ban speech and i i
remember talking to this guy and i was
like dude
how i i hung out with him and then a few
months later he was advocating for
banning alex jones and then i was like i
thought you were the free press and he
was like but this is hate speech i'm
like when did you guys start deciding
that certain things weren't free press
anymore like i don't i don't get it dude
i i pulled up their organization on the
way back machine
and it was like we believe in free
speech in the free press and then you
look at some point all of a sudden it's
like diversity and equity are our core
values and i'm like that's not free
press right yo they lost it you you go
back and you look at the way the left
and the liberals used to write about
twitter used to write about social media
they used to praise them for free speech
they used to praise them for opening up
communications for democratizing the
news until trump wins yeah trump's all
great until trump wins and that's weird
and they realized and they realized how
much institutional power they have and
they realized hey you know we can
prevent trump from winning again let's
exert it and now they're just full-blown
left fascists i mean that's just where
they even used to praise data mining for
elections this is fantastic article
maybe we can put it up it's called you
can you can probably google it you'll
find it it's called obama facebook and
the power of friendship this is the way
they were writing about the way facebook
data was used in 2012.
from the guardian yes
obama facebook and the power of
friendship the power
data election
but then
donald trump did
the same thing actually i don't even
think he did i i do i do think because i
read a lot about the cambridge stuff
yeah no he did far less than this i
think it's lbs facebook gave the obama
campaign their entire social graph like
cambridge analytica was nothing compared
to what facebook did in 2012. and i
think a lot of i think they overhyped
what cambridge was actually doing oh
absolutely absolutely because like
they can't you know whatever let them
lose
these are people who
can't admit to themselves that they suck
and so it's like they're at a party
they've got you know dog crap all over
their boots and no one will go near them
and they're like it's cause i'm too cool
the real problem is
russia russia's telling everybody not to
hang out with me dude rush is so lame
that's what they're doing it's like no
you suck hillary was terrible why would
you run hillary clinton and they did and
it's funny because yo if they picked
literally anybody else trump would not
have won
like they went with one of the least
popular persons yeah bernie sanders
would have beat him for sure yeah i
definitely think bernie sanders would
have won but i think they could have
found like you could have taken any any
moderate democrat
joe biden probably would that's true
2016. but i guess because of his son is
why he didn't run that they they had
planned for joe biden to run oh
hillary was just next in line she was
gonna get it she was not gonna happen
that's very regime
yeah anyone who got in her way you know
that's crazy
metaphorically metaphorically of course
the dnc just chooses the candidate like
that's really crazy yeah the super
delegates and all that i mean that's
what they did did you guys see the meme
the twitter account roe v wade says i
have information that will lead to the
arrest and prosecution of hillary
clinton
anything gets cancelled shut down ends
like a burger shop can go out of
business and someone will make a meme
about hillary clinton i think what what
gets me about this what and i think i'm
trying to see that point of view the
other point of view here is that trump
can go on stage and be like the sky
is not blue
the sky is red
this i heard the sky is red and then a
bunch of people will go online and be
like the sky actually is red and people
be like okay there are such things as
cult worshipers that believe anything
even if it's not real when they hear it
from the occultist when they're called
like so people are afraid of that and
they want to censor it i think backwards
i think he's a very powerful speaker and
people believe him at his word
reads a story about some potential
medications that was published in
techcrunch
because i know because i read the news
two days later donald trump goes did you
hear the news about this thing it sounds
very great there's a medication we're
very excited for this and then the media
all of a sudden flips and is like no
it's all bad donald trump is dangerous
and i'm like but you reported on these
studies donald trump had a tendency of
watching cable tv putting too much stock
in these institutional news outlets
because he kept giving them interviews
believing them but then the next day
they'd be like uh actually i think we
said yesterday is gone here's a good
example politico reported
that ukraine meddled in the 2016
election and then when donald trump and
trump's reporters are complaining about
it politico then reported that ukraine
did not meddle in the i'm like good
stuff are you have you retracted the
initial report yet no
okay you know what man
and so that's actually you know to your
point i think what's happening in
reverse we can point this out that
politico you know basically made
something up and we're able to do that
in the digital public square and correct
people and help them come to the truth
and so with your point if if this was a
good faith argument that they were
making
it's actually better for them to say the
sky is red out in the public square
because we'll be able to correct them
and guide them to where the truth is
unfortunately what they're doing is
they're they're suppressing it and so
you're going to have two americans yeah
that's where it's not overreaction let's
just let's let's just let's
but it could very well because
because i know there are many people who
want to share this show and share the
show with people who are not initiated
in the past several years of politics
here is an article from politico in 2017
uh january of 2017 from ken vogel and
david stern ukrainian efforts to
sabotage trump backfire
ukrainian government officials tried to
help hillary clinton and undermine trump
by publicly questioning his fitness for
office they also disseminated documents
implicating a top trump aid in
corruption and suggested they were
investigating the matter only to back
away after the election and they helped
clinton allies research damaging
information on trump and his advisers a
politico investigation found
they never retracted this this is
damning evidence this is a story that
came out
right after the election that is still
there that has never been retracted but
yes politico and every other outlet came
out
my favorite moment shout out david
pakman when he did a segment about meet
the press asking ted cruz do you think
ukraine meddled in the election and
ted's like it was reported by politico
and like nbc and then a guy in the
background starts laughing
so like it's super unprofessional and
pac-man is like wow they're laughing at
them and i'm like david did you google
the story he they don't do it they live
in crackpot fake news reality where i
can at least say this maybe ukraine did
not meddle in the election maybe
but politico's report both they did and
they didn't so you tell me what's true i
bet they all did at this point it's a
global game and the united states is the
leader so everyone involved everyone's
involved that possibly can but it's good
if there's global meddling to help the
democrats it's only bad if it helps the
republicans um i mean that's their
perspective like honestly one thing that
hurts me about what you just said tim is
that you said did they google it and
we're talking about censorship and who
controls the gateway of what you can see
it's google so like did you google it
does it even matter if google can decide
what's going to be on the google search
results i don't like using google's verb
think of it as a company that has a
search algorithm that is very hidden
from view i use brave as my search well
the fact is that people don't do the
barest amount of research before they
talk about anything including this or
someone like david pakman can just be
like oh my gosh they're laughing at him
that must mean it's crazy right no it's
actually not and if you looked into it
you'd know it it's like one of the first
things to wrap up what i was saying
trump will say something whether it's
true or not people and then people may
or may not believe it they're afraid
that the cultists will believe him at
face value and that's dangerous so they
try and suppress it but i think also
that there's like trump wasn't part of
the liberal economic order he didn't
want american military supremacy all
over the earth and they didn't like that
so now they're going far beyond like hey
this guy's dangerously corrupting people
too this guy's impeding our agenda so
let's make sure that we smash him in the
press
that's the vibe i'm getting from it
and i'm tired of it so we're building
decentralized free software which will
be agpl where you can run your own
network and have your own server and
interact with other people using the
software try and bypass this stuff i'm
still concerned with verizon having isps
and things like that we got to figure
out a way to like use decentralized tech
like noster and ostr stuff like that
where we don't need an internet to
interact with each other it's all meshed
web look at this look at this politico
ukraine ukraine ukraine when russian
disinformation met a trump obsession the
kremlin may have been laying the
groundwork for blaming ukraine for 2016
as early as 2015. oh my gosh what are
you crazy three weeks after election day
2016 the kremlin kremlin officially
floated a theory that would ultimately
lead to only the third presidential
impeachment in us history ukraine
seriously complicated the work of
trump's election by planting information
aimed at damaging his campaign chairman
paul manafort a spokesman for russians
vs foreign ministry told reporters on
november 30th 2016 accusing the
ukrainian government of scheming to help
elect hillary clinton this is the euro
my dan just fascinating just so
fascinating that politico reported that
politico was russian disinformation
okay
okay so look i'll say this maybe it is
maybe politico really is russian
disinformation good job politico why did
you not retract the initial article then
if you're gonna publish a story claiming
it was russian disinformation that
ukraine meddled retract your own story
and apologize you are fake news
fake news
this is also concerning because there
was the government basically there's a
revolution in the ukraine in 2014 you
know the i don't know if the cia was
involved in it but that's what i've
heard that a bunch i can't bear 100
backed by western uh western
intelligence like i don't think that's
even in dispute anymore and so if that's
the government that was meddling to keep
trump out of office it doesn't surprise
me my thing about the whole ukraine war
right now is the us and the west was
using soft power to win over ukraine
that's what they were doing it's better
than kinetic warfare russia is being
terrible at what they do and not
understanding how to compete in fourth
and fifth generation fifth generation
fifth generation warfare decides just
going with bombs and tanks killing
people and destroying a country so
i don't like what the us was doing when
they do these manipulation campaigns but
i think the reality of the world is that
everything is influence peddling china's
going for the you know the was it the
belt and road initiative or whatever
they're going and they're offering money
the us going to ukraine to be like we're
going to give you a billion dollars
we're going to give you all this stuff
get us what we want i'm like okay
welcome to global politics joe biden
going in and being like fire the
prosecutor are you not getting the
billion dollars joe biden should be in
prison for that
but you know i think russia is wrong it
seems like the liberal economic order is
the borg and that the russian that
confederation federation is the klingons
like they're just brute brute force yeah
the russian soft power like really is
pitiful compared to the us all these
myths about you know the kgb and their
uh you know
in insane covet abilities i mean they
weren't able to stop a coup happening on
a country right in their border
uh us off power really is unparalleled
even compared to china's i would say
although china's catching up it's it's
tough because
i don't like war i don't like uh
conflict and violence and bombs and
nukes and all that stuff
but if if it's like if the line is the
us goes to countries and they're like
we're gonna give you a bunch of money to
side with us i'm like isn't that better
in terms of global interests to like at
least
sort of trade kind of you get look at
the economic the confessions of an
economic hitman he wrote about that they
come in and they offer money and then
but if you say no that's when the
problem begins because then they're like
okay now we've got to send this
jackals here's the thing with ukraine
though you're kind of asking for trouble
if you do that to a country on the
borders of a great power estonia and
latvia are nato countries on the border
of russia i think the issue is that
russia needs the warm water port with
with crimea and so
that's a big issue for russia the u.s is
encroaching and i think russia is one of
the next dominoes to fall so russia
probably tolerated estonia and latvia
with ukraine they were like ukraine goes
in 20 years we go you take a look at
what happened with those instagramers
from russia crying no don't ban me
russia already lost the culture war or i
should say they're losing it and now
they're trying to reverse it but man are
they late
their their children were being
indoctrinated by western social media
and so they were freaking out when
russia declared this war
i'm telling you man
the difference between
boomers and even millennials and down
this gap in internet usage
people like putin and his advisors his
top military guys they don't understand
that the cultural and mental worldview
difference they have from their kids
because their kids weren't raised by
them their kids were raised by the
internet and they were being raised by
facebook face cia book as the activists
like to call it
so what happens after vladimir putin
ages out as it were you can't spell
facial without cia
this is one of the big reasons why the
establishment was praising facebook and
twitter and social media for their free
speech before trump because i think
there was there was a a chap who worked
in the trump administration an appointee
uh i won't name him who said uh the uh
and this was like you
follows follow the for the foreign
policy part of the deep state very
closely he said um
the u.s establishment the defense
establishment like social media because
it helped them do regime change abroad
but then with 2016 and brexit they
realized oh no can regime change the
west
that's what i'm wondering it's like it's
like we're in an avalanche this whole
globalizing internet culture
and how what we can't stop the avalanche
i mean i can't fathom that so we just
got to ski the avalanche i mean at this
point build technology like yeah open
source free software and it's hard even
for companies like google and twitter
and facebook uh to do it because these
are all started as open platforms so you
still can find articles and your videos
debunking this political stuff if with
enough creative google searches you
could find it on twitter going viral uh
they they haven't been able to censor
these these uh platforms completely
because these platforms were not made to
be censored which by the way is why the
left is furious with them i mean the
left wants total control here that's
where you know as much from the right we
see big tech as being sensorious and
terrible and all that and they have been
the left wants them to double down
triple down i mean it's absolutely
insane i mean you know my entire job is
is exposing big tech but if we're
talking about the the regime
big tech is not entirely a reluctant
partner but they have they they were
pressured into it
to a large degree by external forces
especially the media
and this is why we see these 26
organizations coming and saying we need
an advertiser boycott of twitter because
that's their leverage over the tech
companies ultimately that's how they get
them to do things yeah you know what
elon musk was trying to get away from
ads anyway he knows exactly what he's
doing he's thought about this
he wants to do a subscription membership
model he wants to charge for premium
access and i think it's a brilliant idea
and i'll i will i'll be totally honest
uh i got a lot of followers on twitter
if they came to me and said we've got a
premium suite i'd be like done yes
show me like show me data on uh there's
like there's the analytics sucks for
twitter give me like a premium analytics
suite
i don't i don't care about twitter
because you can't use it the way you can
use say youtube youtube tells me here's
how many people watched your video in
the first hour here's how many people
like how long they watched your first
video and i'm like oh okay so here's
what they like they don't like twitter
is like say something and cross your
fingers
if they actually came out and said for x
amount of dollars we'll do this for you
i think they should be verifying
everybody
i think you know i i guess elon musk
said he wants what like two bucks um two
bucks per month for twitter blue and
then they'll verify you though your
identity and all that stuff not everyone
has to be identify identified not
everybody has to be verified
people will still be able to use it for
free and i'm like i think he's got a
good plan for this so and he's he's so
smart i mean i i know he made comments
about this isn't about economics which
is great like i'm glad that he's doing
this for for free speech but he's too
smart for that like he knows that he
paid 44 billion dollars he's got web 3
ideas he's got decentralization ideas
he's got all sorts of things right well
sure i'm sure he will turn this into a
trillion dollar company i would bet my
this i'm not sure he has web3 ideas he
constantly uh constantly dunks on web3
projects
uh which which to be fair a lot of them
are a bit
bad yeah shout out to hive and the
recovery of the steam network i think
elon in this situation is a student he's
been the master at all his other
companies because he started them this
one he bought so he's here to learn how
cool would it be if after elon buys
twitter one day everyone wakes up and
when they log in they just see
when they log into their account it's
just geocities
and there's like just like the banana
guy the peanut butter jelly time you
know gifs and all that stuff and people
like wait what's going on and elon's
like the internet was better back when
we just did it this way so now twitter
is this and it's like just
you're reminding me of uh ytm nds
remember those i remember those
those were those were 4chan before
fortunately that was amazing
you guys ever go on new grounds oh yeah
back in the day yeah that's crazy
newgrounds.com for those that don't know
was youtube before youtube existed and
they missed the train
they had time they yeah they had flash
video because they were cartoon oriented
and so what happened was i could be
totally wrong about this um i used to i
was on newgrounds every day looking at
every new submission these were people
were uploading cartoons they decided to
do flash animation stuff
and then i remember when youtube came
around and then all of a sudden the
animators started putting their stuff on
youtube because
it was just easy and fast
new grounds could have done video in
fact they had some video sometimes but i
i guess they thought no no we're an
animator community so we're going to
stick to that and then everyone migrated
their animations to youtube and that was
and they probably were they were so big
they didn't see the threat coming but
but the crazy thing is they were so big
but nowhere near as big as youtube
came to be
do you remember the ultimate showdown i
was i was of course i was nine i thought
it was the funniest [ __ ] ever imagine if
right now we were streaming not on
youtube but on new grounds because they
they had
flash player they they could have done
video imagine if they built out that
infrastructure we'd be in a very
different place i wonder what what they
would do because a lot of the content
they posted is just adult
humor like not for kids
yeah could you comment on videos on new
grounds yeah yeah yeah of course youtube
had those video responses which really
enlivened the community before google
bought them i wonder if google was
planning on buying them before that or
if they were like whoa there's a
community here and we want to build
communities so we're going to buy it but
they bought it for a billion and youtube
was dying was like they couldn't pay for
their their infrastructure so they had
to sell the company that's what it what
it came to thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you